hey guys it's Daniel here from DLM model
lifestyle
I'm here with photographer Nikita I'll
add a link in the description so you can
check out her photos today in this video
I'm gonna show you how to do male model
poses for men I thought it's better to
do it while we're doing the photo shoot
so then you can see how it looks like in
real life so let's start of the basics
so what is male poses? well it's just you
basically facing the camera and showing
your best angles to get a good shot now
the first thing that you need to get
used to is people in the background
whether you're in location shoots or in
the studio there's going to be some
people looking at you all the time so
you have to get used to this there's a
lot of factors that comes into posing
it's not just you
it's the type of lights the type of
photographer it's the location that you
are playing with it's the clothes that you
have on the hairstyle that you have it's a
lot of things but today is just the
basics so we are just working on the
basic modeling poses and what you want
to do is you want to remember these
angles the front angle left 45 and right
45 these are your main three angles your
left side might be better or for some
your right side might be better it
depends on your angles but mostly you
use these three angles where you look
directly to the camera 45 degrees to the
left and 45 to the right
the second thing that you need to
remember is that not everybody is so
natural in front of the camera for some
it is very natural to pose in front of the
camera and for some it takes a little
bit of practice so don't be too hard on
yourself just get used to it and then
once you get those three angles down
there are three different poses main
poses just standing just normal standing
pose and then you have walking poses as well
so you can play around with it a little
bit the third tip that I can give you is
you add these different angles which is
different kind of poses so whether
you're walking or you're standing or if
you're sitting down do it in all these
different angles of course there are
more so you can look at the camera
where Nikita is and look totally 90
degrees and add something interesting
but I'll talk a lot about those kind of
things later on in some other videos
subscribe if you want to check those out
anyway  let's get back to the
basic beginner male model poses
so you walk stand a little bit keep
different directions alright so one
thing that you need to remember
is the direction and angle of your face
it's very important your body has these
three angles right but with your face
you can look everywhere like you will
look in real life so let's do a few
where I just stand left 45 degrees
direction look at how many different
poses I can do by just changing my face
and a little bit of my body
you also need to remember the type of Photographer that you shoot with
some shoot very fast
so you need to move while they shoot and
normally you hear it click sound and
then you know the photo is done so you
change some photographers take a long
time to focus and others they do it fast
so you can just keep on moving and they
get their shots in play around
with your hands play with your face
expressions look far look near look to
the camera and play with your body you
see your body and your face they play
together they work together to get a
good picture with the type of clothes
that you have on another thing that you
need to remember is if the photographer  comes closer to you it usually is just upper
body shot but if they're a little bit
further away you know it's a full body
shot
so when Nikita is close like this you
have to remember to play with your
expressions and keep your upper body in
different directions like this it
doesn't matter how you look here from
this part here down sometimes you can
move a lot and keep these interesting
poses working with the clothes and with
your hands but sometimes just normal
basic poses is really good
just standing and looking at different
directions so there's a lot of different
hand poses that you can do if the
photographer's close to you like this
bring your hands up a little bit
play around
so these are upper body shots but if
the Photographer wants to do full length
shots play around with your legs do some walking poses
do the type of poses that looks natural and normal
don't fake them don't do this kind of weird poses
just be normal and natural
remember the angles, I am playing around with just these 3 angels all the time
Left 45 to the camera what makes a
model really good if you have big
variety of model poses now you need to
learn how to pose in different
directions different facial expressions
with different clothes the best tip is
natural is best I'm going to pose for
you just natural poses without even
putting my hands in my pockets or really
using them I'm just gonna use the angles
45 degrees to the left to the camera 45
degrees to the right walking and
standing post that's it look how that's
done
alright guys there you have it now you
know how to do male modeling poses for
beginners but before you go I just want
to give a big thanks to Nikita she's an
awesome awesome photographer and I will add a link in the description so you can check out
her work she's also my wife which is
pretty awesome because I can get new
test shoots whenever I want but thank
you so much for checking out this video
if you want to see some more videos
about modeling please subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video